[Music]
last month at the military Women's
Memorial in D.C 49 female veterans all
breast cancer survivors had their
portraits hung in solidarity proudly
displaying the scars of mastectomy
surgeries that would normally be hidden
but these 49 are far from alone a 2009
Pentagon study found that women in the
armed forces are 20 to 40 percent more
likely to be diagnosed with breast
cancer than their civilian counterparts
bringing that issue into focus is one
professional photographer who's made it
her mission to put a face on the disease
to further Express that point this story
will include portraits showing survivors
bare-chested images as raw as the
emotions behind them
hold yourself up tall hold your chin up
high using more than just her lens to
draw out her subjects photographer
Sharice Isis and lift your chin up
captures their Spirit beautiful creating
transformational images of breast cancer
survivors who've lost one or both of
their breasts to the disease it is
unbelievable how open they are with you
with that vulnerability
I think they see the pictures that I've
been doing and they see these women
standing in their power and their beauty
and they they're like I want a portrait
of me like that the photographs which
total more than 600 to date are part of
a collection that's initial idea can be
traced back to one woman who'd undergone
a mastectomy but still pose topless for
Charisse in a Boudoir photo shoot she
said I have a confession to make I'm a
12 year breast cancer survivor I feel
mutilated under my clothing I've never
shown anyone my scars in that moment I'm
behind the camera like I had goosebumps
I'm thinking to myself wow I'm
witnessing somebody let go of like 12
years of Shame what was it like to be a
part of that it felt magical I mean it
was as cathartic for me as it was for
her and I realized that I needed to put
something out there that put a face on
breast cancer that showed some beauty
and courage and Grace in 2009 the app
named Grace Project officially began
Charisse collecting stories and taking
pictures of women who'd undergone
mastectomy surgery with a symbolic goal
of 800 portraits there are about 800 new
diagnosis in the United States every day
for breast cancer and then I thought
what a powerful thing if I could have
800 portraits hanging in one space at
one time so you could truly see the
impact of breast cancer in America
for Creative inspiration she turned to
the Venus de Milo a Hellenistic goddess
who's broken but beautiful and strong as
for the title the word Grace stems from
the word it means gratitude it's the
word for thanks it means a gift and it
also talks about the grace of the body
so it had sort of this whole multiple
meaning to it and while no Survivor
story is the same Charisse has put some
in their own category the Athena
division launched in 2015 it's dedicated
to military veterans actually just a
little bit right about there in the
middle there like Sheila Johnson I
joined the United States Air Force in
1985. I did 25 years four months and 27
days I'm counting all of them Sheila
retired when she was diagnosed with
metastatic breast cancer at age 43. I
want you to think about the strength and
the pride she credited her military
service with some of the resiliency and
fight needed to battle her cancer for
the last 12 years I know that Sheila
feels very blessed because she's had a
lot of time but when I started
photographing her like the emotion just
started pouring out of her immediately I
mean she had tears streaming down her
face if you start to feel emotional just
just be with it
just be with it don't fight it it took
me back when I was diagnosed and I cried
when they told me I had to get out to
military but then you're looking at all
these flags in a room and I see the
United States Air Force flag and I was
proud I'm proud to have served my
country I guess you're never fully done
with breast cancer right no so is
Barbara aren't we served for four years
in the Marine Corps though she also
calls her service a confusing time after
she says she was sexually assaulted
while doing her specialty training at
Camp Lejeune I didn't report it I didn't
tell anybody but you know I knew you
don't talk about that come on we're
going this way yes good girl Barbara
says she learned to push her feelings
aside once she'd later be forced to face
as she was at age 41 when she was
diagnosed with breast cancer how did you
decide to have the double mastectomy it
wasn't a thought in my mind I knew that
I didn't want my breasts anymore I felt
like my body betrayed me and I'm sorry
but I had really nice breasts I really
liked them my breasts my hair and then
they were gone so you know I just shut
down for Barbara the Athena project
helped open her back up when I
photographed her I could see emotion
welling up in her and I think that that
really surprised her that's it don't
fight that feeling I can see that you've
got emotion that wants to come up and
she talked about you know you're a
marine you have to be tough you've got
to just keep pushing through you know
she did that with her cancer so she was
emotional in her photo shoot and it was
a really beautiful moment with her I
stood in Central Park topless and I
didn't feel weird at all I felt really
empowered it was like wow like I'm still
here and I was really mindful of being
able to watch people objectively and
nobody was like oh gross or put a top on
she credits the Athena project with what
she called The Gift of being comfortable
in her own skin for the longest time I
thought that I was never going to be
with man again like I was just going to
become this Old Maid because you know
one of my favorite attributes about
myself was gone so like what do I have
to offer you I'm never ever going to
take my top off and the fact of the
matter is is that it doesn't matter what
I look like it's not about my looks it's
about who's in here
it's a sentiment Cherise Isis never
tires of hearing you seem to take this
scar that for some is shame and you turn
it into strength which is an amazing
thing
yeah well you know a scar is it's the
sign that you have gotten through
something really big and you're still
here
that's the sign of a fighter yeah
absolutely and these women are the
military women are definitely Fighters
and obviously all of these breast cancer
survivors are one of the things that
everyone we spoke with really hopes that
this Athena division can do is not just
raise awareness we know breast cancer is
out there but the VA is dealing with a
female population that is the largest
the fastest growing population among it
and they need to start working towards
helping these women battle the disease
and find earlier detection
800 people diagnosed every day every day
approximately and we'll be right